can i just check you can hear me
yes we can
thank you very much
i just wanted to do a check i'm not very
good at this
should be used to it by now
yeah
okay chair we're live now
okay
thank you natalie okay
can i welcome everybody to the licensing
subcommittee meeting for tuesday the
24th of may
uh first item is attendances which uh
have been recorded
um the second item and the main item of
the evening is the
application for the grant of a full
variation
to a premises license under section 34
the licensing act 2003
that vetoes
184 ashley road hail
um
so i'm councillor john and i'll be
chairing the hearing i've got
councillors thomas and wetton with me on
the
on the licensing sub committee
and we also have offices from from
licensing legal and governance
now
do we have the applicant here mr dunn or
is he being represented
both evening chair um
my name is felicity i'm representing mr
dunn today but as you can see on your
screen
heyman's here as well
okay that's fine
okay
right
um and we have
ms marshall
uh the neighbor
and
ms marshall i think you've been on the
screen so
it's a good evening yes i'm here yes
okay thanks very much
and counselor young
who's coming through now loud and clear
yes sir
right i think that's all the
participants in the meeting so
what i propose to do i'm going to read
the procedure for tonight's hearing
right through and then so everybody's
clear
about about what's happening and then
and then we'll start the meeting
so
the first stage is i'll ask the
licensing officer to outline the
application
i will then ask the applicant or their
representative to address the
subcommittee and call any witnesses
the applicant and each of their
witnesses may then be questioned by
members of the subcommittee
officers and any other party making
representation
the party making representation it will
be referred to as the representative
and or their representative
will then be given an opportunity to
address the subcommittee and call any
witnesses
the representative and any of their
witnesses may
then be questioned by members of the
subcommittee
officers and any other party making
representation
if they're more than one representative
they will be heard in the following
order which is um the public
representation
miss marshall
and uh councillor patricia young
after this i will request all parties
involved to summarise
the
representatives will be given two
minutes to summarize
followed by the applicant who will also
be given two minutes to summarise
the subcommittee will then retire to
consider their decision
and then i will announce determine the
application and the reasons for the
determination
this will be confirmed in writing within
five days of the hearing
so is everybody clear about the process
for the
hearing right thank you
right in that case i'll ask the
licensing officer
is it miss pickup
or miss armstrong
yeah thank you chair okay thank you very
much if you'd like to find the
application please yeah uh thank you
and so a premise license is required in
respect of any premises where it is
intended to conduct one or more of the
full licensing activities these being
the sale of alcohol the supply of
alcohol regulated entertainment and for
the provision of late night refreshment
so this full variation application was
submitted by ashley foods limited in
respect of vetoes of 184 ashley rhode
hale wa 14 9sf
licensing authority is satisfied that
the application has been properly made
and all procedures have been correctly
followed
the applicant has applied to extend the
sale of alcohol on and off the premises
and to extend the opening hours
so they want to extend the alcohol on
and off sunday to wednesday twelve
o'clock midday to twelve o'clock
midnight
thursday to saturday twelve o'clock
midday to half past midnight
and the opening hours to be amended to
sunday to wednesday twelve o'clock
midday to half past midnight and
thursday to saturday twelve o'clock
midday till one o'clock
through a copy of the current license
and the plan is attached as appendix c
in the report this application has been
referred to the license and subcommittee
because during the consultation period
we received two representations one from
councillor young and one from a local
resident mrs marshall in the both
relation into both relation to public
nuisance a copy of these are attached to
the pending appendix d to the report
the subcommittee is asked to consider
the application and the representations
of all parties to make its decision
the options open to the subcommittee are
to grant the application in full and on
the terms and conditions contained
within the application to include any
applicable mandatory conditions
to grant the application but modified to
such an extent is considered appropriate
to satisfy any relevant representations
and to promote the licensing objectives
or finally to reject the application
that's the end of my summary of the
application unless the subcommittee has
any questions for me at this stage
thank you ms armstrong did any anybody
does everybody understand that and does
everybody anybody have any questions of
a licensing officer
not sure thanks
so fine okay then um could i ask miss
tullock then on behalf of the uh the
applicant if she would
speak to the uh to the application
police
thank you very much chair um yes
absolutely the application is exactly as
katie has set out it's an application to
vary the license for vito's pizza
kitchen
uh you'll be aware of the location of
the premises it's on ashley road in the
middle of hale village
as you can see from the plans within the
papers in front of you the premises
trades over ground and first floor
spaces
with
approximately 40 covers
for customers within it
it's been open for around two years now
eamonn who also owns the elk bar
opposite acquired the site just before
the pandemic struck in march 2020 so
it's had a bit of a rocky start in terms
of its ability to trade however it's
managed to weather the storm
and has operated as restrictions have
allowed over the last couple of years
but now things are on a more even keel
uh it's proving very popular
and what amen is finding is that there
is a demand for people to want to stay
later into the evening he doesn't want
to breach his license or
ask people to leave unnaturally early or
before they finish their evening and so
has applied to amend it which is why
we're before you this evening as katie
outlined the existing license allows the
sale of alcohol until 11 pm daily
at the moment at 11 pm if customers want
to continue with their evening they
obviously have to leave often they're
directed to eamonn's other premises
across the road or indeed they might go
elsewhere into hale village so the
purpose of this application
is to create an environment where
customers can stay a little bit later
and to stop that migration
the hours applied for aren't out of sync
when compared with other premises in the
immediate vicinity
um so as i say that that demand
and um growing business
uh
meant that eamonn lodged an application
back in march to seek midnight during
the week and half midnight at weekends
as katie's already outlined there's no
application for live or recorded music
or any other licensable activities
there have been no representations from
the police
pc john lloyd as you can see in the
papers in front of you confirm that gnp
had no issues with the application but
if the license is granted they'll
monitor the premises and if the
additional hours cause problems they'll
they'll deal with anything arising at
that point
there was a representation from richard
pollock from the environmental health
team
he wanted additional conditions to be
added to the license
including some which go to the heart of
the issues being discussed this evening
such as no noise nuisance must be caused
to nearby noise sensitive premises doors
and windows must be kept closed at all
times the premises is open
uh a ban on external speakers
and a condition which prevents refuse
from being disposed of or collected from
the premises between 9 p.m and 8 8 a.m
the following morning during the week
and not at all on sundays and eamon was
happy to agree to all of those and
they'll be attached to the license
if you're minded to grant variation this
evening
and it would be our view that if you
were to that would create a robust
operating schedule um which would ensure
the promotion of the licensing
objectives
so i've just turned to the um the two
outstanding objective objections uh one
from miss marshall and one from
councillor young you have both of them
before you and they're both here
obviously this evening to elaborate upon
them and so i'll leave them to do that
um but eamonn has read
both of them carefully and you'll also
see in your papers has responded to each
of them at length uh addressing
he hopes the concerns that they raise
that said um
eamon wants to be a good neighbour and
so he's happy to make some further
additional amendments to the application
um and they're over and above the
conditions agreed with the environmental
health team
firstly
a reduction
to the hours applied for to midnight
daily
so that would mean that um
he would be seeking an additional hour
daily
rather than additional hour and a half
for weekends so um the sale of alcohol
to midnight daily plus no more than 30
minutes thereafter for dispersal
secondly
a condition which prevents off sales
after 11 pm this was raised as a
potential issue in both representations
um and
eamonn's happy to offer that to ensure
that there's no danger of any street
drinking or or whatever i mean
off sales currently um
comprise you know sealed bottles of wine
for example from diners who want to take
um perhaps a you know half drunk bottle
of wine home um
but
um
eamon is alive to the concerns raised
and so is happy to offer a condition
along those lines as well
thirdly
a condition
which requires the premises licence
holder to make available a dedicated
email address where issues can be logged
by neighbours
this email account to be monitored and
any queries responded to promptly
in the papers before you can see that
in ayman's response to ms marshall
he sets out that email address its
complaints at veto's pizza kitchen dot
co dot uk um and amy is happy to share
that more widely to ensure that if
anyone else has any queries or concerns
um
that that's the
the quickest and um easiest form of
communication um so more than happy to
offer a condition that requires that
inbox to be monitored and maintained
fourthly that the front of the premises
shall be swept of litter at the end of
each evening and more frequently if
required
and fifthly the passageway um which is
behind some gates uh should be kept neat
and tidy at all times
we would hope that the addition of those
conditions combined with the reduction
in the hours applied for
uh would ensure the premise doesn't
cause an issue
for miss marshall as aymond's nearest
neighbor
so that's the application um
in summary
we'd ask you to grant it in its amended
form the licensing act as you wear are
aware is about
balance partnership working um
we hope that the amended application
strikes that balance ensuring
the viability of the premises ensuring
that it trades and upholds the licensing
objectives but also um takes into
account the needs of marshall next door
as well so unless you have any questions
for myself or um
unless ayman wants to add anything
further that's the application thank you
okay thank you very much so so just to
clarify i think um
just appreciated you you've reached out
on on the hours
um but all the are the opening i was
remaining the same
apologize if i missed that
they would be they would be reduced so
the
um
the original application asked for the
sale of apple until midnight
sunday to wednesday plus 30 minutes and
until half midnight plus 30 minutes on
thursdays fridays and saturdays
so the amendments would bring back
thursdays fridays and saturdays in line
with sunday to wednesday so
um midnight plus 30 minutes daily would
be the
um would be the amendment
okay
right thank you very much for clarifying
that um yeah well a couple of questions
really the um regarding the the
the door the kitchen door that was a
that was seemingly
being almost permanently left open
during during operations
um there is already on the the old
license and
the operating schedule
um two conditions for
closing the door i think number 12 and
number 18.
um
so you know basically i mean
we would just be asking you to you know
um to comply with it really and want to
know why why hasn't
been complied with
it with up to now
this might be an answer um best made by
eamonn
regarding the back door
yeah i think the the back door has been
um
open at times of time from our kitchen
pool to cleaning stuff out the back is
certainly our intention to have the door
open permanently at all and obviously
they've got to access the bins and the
litter out the back
um i think i've got another cc tv camera
that i can place over the door anyway to
monitor
externally it needs to be in any event
but it's not our intention to have the
door open
other than to
access the um the rear area to either
go to the bins or to clean items
um during shift but generally during
shift and during trade it's not our
intention to have it open at all
okay thank you um i'll just ask you
about the the air conditioning which is
a subject of some debate
um
you said you've recently upgraded it but
you
you appeared to offer to upgrade upgrade
it in the uh
in the kitchen
area particularly
um i just i just wondered if you could
clarify that and just tell us if it's
going to happen when it's going to
happen and how you're going to ensure
that the the noise is not is not an
issue with with your neighbour
well
yeah well since the application we've
installed additional air conditioning to
the first floor
and so is to ensure that any windows
can't be open the rear window of the
first floor level is not is not
accessible
anymore
um because we basically we don't need it
because we have got air conditioning
we've got air conditioning on the ground
floor as well
i fitted a new shop front to the
premises which is all double glazed
and to the rear what i was talking about
was the rear extraction
is upgrading our extraction system in
the rear prep kitchen
and that you've already done have you no
it's not done yet i'm waiting for a
quotation on that at the moment
right and
reference was made also to the outside
drinking area particularly with
reference to not not using it after 11
00 p.m
but you can't see on your plan exactly
where where it is would you be
yeah yeah i think last year we did have
a couple of tables out the front but
this year we have not got any tables out
in front of our premises at all and it
isn't our intention currently to have
them
all right so there were there were
actually there were tables out the front
with with people
taking drinks yeah just a couple of
tables absolutely
when the uh when the sun was out
but uh as of this year we certainly
haven't we don't have the tables anymore
anyway that is not our intention to pull
them out
okay thank you mr dunn i'll just ask if
any colleagues have any
questions
i don't think sure
that's a quick one for clarification uh
if i could ask it of mr dunn please the
you mentioned about the extraction from
your your kitchen
um
and there is a um
in the
complaints there is about the one
one about food smells
cooking smells
um
for clarification have you got a
uh a high extract chimney in it in
effect flu is probably a proper word for
it um
or is that what you're looking at
yes we do have that yes i'm looking at
whether i can
basically connect into that from my prep
kitchen to send any odors of the large
flu area
right so
work in progress that should deal with
yeah yeah yes
i think as felicity said it's not our
intention to cause any issues with any
of our neighbors we want to try and work
with them but
at the moment it's difficult to get
quotations quickly we've asked for a
quotation and wait for it to come in
right okay
thank you
okay thank you councillor
i'm gonna discuss the representatives um
starting with ms marshall if they wish
to
ask questions of the uh of the applicant
or their representative but
just just questions at this stage
because you you will get a chance to
make a statement
later
um
no questions um
i dispute the door not being kept open
though
um
but you've already mentioned that so i
don't want to go over all ground but
mr dunn may say that he doesn't want the
door open but the fact of the matter is
the door is being open
not just for people going out it's being
left open and also if there was an
extraction
surely the door would have to be closed
for the extraction to be used properly
is that a question to
mr dunn
well whoever i'm not going
well i can answer that i'm not an
extraction expert but i would assume if
i upgrade our extraction there'll be
absolutely no leads have any door open
other than
um for
accessing the rear area us and when we
need it
i suppose i think i'm just trying to
make the point
uh as i tried to set out in my
correspondence is that we've no desire
to cause any issues to antibody if we
needed to upgrade our extraction then
we'll do so indeed we're looking at
doing it now
i haven't had any correspondence other
than me sending my correspondence
i did email you in response to your uh
to you i i haven't received an email i
haven't received an email
right well there's a copy of it in the
bundle i think
i haven't had any emails from mr dunn
other than the ones
last year regarding
the extraction which was making very big
noise but i've had nothing else no i've
had no emails
well that's unfortunate really because i
mean it is in the pack um
it should be you should have a copy of
the pack but um it does address a lot of
the issues that you raised in your your
email
particularly about the door but um
well surely they would they would have
come from yourselves wouldn't they as i
had to send everything to yourself
uh well he
he sent it to you i believe he copied
the licensing section in so everybody
should have got a copy of the same email
nothing
okay well
we'll have to
to deal with that really have you got a
copy of the agenda papers
are you talking about
the meeting today yes the copy of the
pack
yes i think it's some
one of the last pages
54
yeah
yeah page 54.
if if you want to have a read of that
well um
counselor young wants to ask any
questions um
okay you can get up to speed with that
sorry well that's obviously unfortunate
there's been a bit of a breakdown but it
does address a lot of the issues that
you raised in your correspondence
so hopefully
it'll be to your satisfaction but please
let us know if they're not
okay
counselor young
yes thank you
i don't think i've received a report
back actually i've had the standard
emails that have gone backwards and
forward between us and licensing
but i haven't had anything remotely
resembling a large pack
however leaving that aside for the
moment there is one question i i'd like
to
to ask um
you've said that
eamonn would be prepared
to
risk to
not have any sales
after 11 p.m to to the public
this is the new one of the new
conditions to
go on to the um
assuming you grant this
does this also
include
the sales that i believe have been made
in the past
when
people who are
occupying the premises
of the elk
have asked for
pizzas
presumably pizzas not actually drinks
from the
veto site and they're going backwards
and forwards across the street
will the is it still proposed to let
those take place right up until midnight
or however long it goes on for while elk
is open
because
in in the way in a certain way they're
just across the street from each other
and almost almost i think possibly if i
was an employee
in one of the two sites you'd be tempted
very much to try and treat the two sides
almost as part of the same thing you see
what i'm getting at
um
counseling i i would perhaps just say
that um
the sale of pizzas up until 11 isn't a
licenseable activity um i don't know
whether that happens but there's nothing
within an answer
but there's nothing within a like within
the licensing regime that governs that
pizzas can be sold until 11 without any
any form of permission
but after that they they don't intend to
carry on after i'm thinking not to
members of the public who walk in but
specifically carrying them across to the
elk yeah the application doesn't request
late night refreshments so that can't
happen
okay
okay
thank
you have any other questions
counselor young
the new except except again as i would
echo what to what miss marshall said
about the door it does seem to be open
all the time i've been assured when i
spoke to eamonn
i did not have a meeting with him but i
couldn't do it at the time because i had
a really bad cold and i didn't want to
infect him
but he assured me that the door was
being kept closed and i'm captioning not
you available it with uh mr dawn
no it's still being left open
i have i addressed it with him and
towards the end of march when we had the
meeting i think it was shortly after
easter and i haven't got the exact date
somewhere maybe around the 24th or a bit
later
and i did ask this and he did the show
me and yet the door remains continuously
open
well maybe we can use this hearing as a
bit of a watershed and move on from here
because it is in the conditions there's
two conditions which require them to
keep doors and windows closed so
we hope that
they would now abide by that
i think with this reminder really i
think um well i'm not aware of it being
left open continuously as council young
suggests
um
i'm quite happy to appoint cctv over the
door to monitored externally i monitor
the cctv of the premises when i'm off
the premises both in respect to vetoes
and in elk and i'm quite happy to
monitor it externally and i can contact
the managing director anytime i want to
so i think there's any issue at all with
us
me monitoring it ourselves and indeed if
the manager doesn't arrange for it to be
shut which i've asked him to do then it
will go down a disciplinary procedure
with them
but on
on a general level there's no need for
the door to be open say accessing
anything that we require in the back
area which would be access to the bins
or any any product that's out there that
we need to get
right so from now from now on it
shouldn't be there's obviously been a
miscommunication somewhere along the
line but
that should now be addressed
yeah i'm happy to address that without
without a doubt but as i say i think
well the way you're hiking it monitor it
is um by pointing one of the cctv
cameras at it directly and i can monitor
it externally ourselves
and if it's still left open obviously
they've got your phone number and email
100 and uh in my email it is we i did
set out there's an email address now
complaints at and if ms marshall or
anyone else wants to make a complaint or
raise an issue that the door is open or
anything else please send an email to
that address it will come directly to me
and i will deal with it
okay thank you mr dunn um does anybody
else have any further questions for mr
dunn
no thanks joe
can i just ask one more
if richard you know richard pollard has
made
um a request that there should be no
waste disposal between 9 p.m and 8 a.m
if that is the case there should be no
need for anybody to go in and out of the
back door to go to the waste bins
or am i is there
am i thinking
along they might have another reason
don't they clean the trays or something
i think
because that
causes causes
rose if you're throwing bottles in the
waste bins or anything oh yeah but there
is a condition on that
council young
well if i could interject that 100
accept that position we already have
that in respect of the elk we keep all
our bottles indoors until the following
day when we open of course we recognize
if we're tipping bottles into a bin it's
going to make significant noise and will
be an inconvenience and a nuisance to
those around us so we're already aware
of that i can't say they're never going
to want to go out into the backyard
after 9 p.m there may be
a beer barrel that we need to get there
may be something out of the backyard
that the staff need to get so to say
that they're never going to want to go
into the backyard i can't give you 100
guarantee about that but in terms of
disposing of bottles and litter etc yeah
i don't see an issue there at all
i'll just i can just read out the
current condition 20 20 on the current
license said no refuge shall be disposed
of or collected from the premises
between the hours of 1900 hours
i know 800 hours monday to saturday
and not at all on sundays or bank
holidays so that's actually in the
current license and is adopted in the
operating schedule
so obviously that would have to be
adhered to
the way i read that is that i i think
that means collection of their waste
bins by
uh either
uh it won't be council they'd have to
pay for the declaration but waste
removal by a company to get rid of their
business waste not not tipping things
like
food obviously bottles has been covered
but i i read it as the removal of waste
uh
bins to be disposed of off-premises it
says disposed or collected i mean it's
something we can talk about we might
need to beef it up a bit you know
we're going to go with that and there's
no reason to to remove it obviously but
we'll we'll have a look at that
in the recess
is there any further questions of the
applicant
well counselor german can i just um
ascertain will i be given a chance to
i have prepared a statement which i do
wish to be able to read out
right yes will will i have give will i
be given time to read that because i
think some questions will come from that
yes have you got the statement there you
read ready yes
yes i don't know when you want i don't
want to interrupt your meeting i just
want to know when
well if we finish with the questions for
the applicant then i i we we we move on
to your representation so okay you're
quite happy to to hear that now
okay
thomas did you ever oh no no oh sorry i
thought you were just twinning a pen
david as i'm right
all right sorry i didn't want to miss
you if you did no no sorry yeah okay
miss marshall if you'd like to
right okay
i appreciate there may be some things
that people contradict or whatever so if
you can just listen to what i've put and
then
obviously you can address whatever
counselor german
so i have put
i have lived here for over 50 years
so i'm a long long-term resident
and 48 of those the next door property
has been a shop
so historically there's never been a bar
or a food place here whatsoever
the shop had normal time zones and
certainly no sunday or bank holiday
openings it was peaceful and quiet
however during covid this changed
despite opposition from myself
and now i have to deal with extra noise
and smells the defuler establishment
incurs
as well as a considerable amount of
stuff in the passageway
and a quantity of beer barrels right
outside my front door for no apparent
reason
there always appears to be stuff in the
passageway either on breaks vaping
smoking or working
but this passageway is shared as the
side gate to my garden
and my front door are both in the
passageway
to have these new late hours
has to be for consumption of alcohol as
very few people eat after 10 10 30.
in fact
pizza express a similar pizza
establishment closes every night ten
o'clock
and that is only a hundred yards or so
up the road
however elk a larger bar diagonally
opposite is owned by the same people who
own vetoes
and i believe there will be a crossover
of drinkers
they already carry pizzas across the
road to elk
in fact not only do they carry pizzas
across
they drag high metal bar stores or bar
tables by holding drinks
that people stand around outside
and extra chairs and bar stools
and then they bring these back in the
late evening often banging the gate and
have woken me up twice
they house these in lean two sheds that
have recently been built by vetoes
in our shared passageway
i'm drawing this to your attention to
show that there is a direct link between
these two places
and i believe this will grow bigger if
you increase the hours of vetoes
drinkers or people who consume alcohol
quite frequently become louder and that
means more noise late at night
as you know you cannot drink and dry so
either people are going to be stumbling
home because by definition if you're out
that late at night you would have had
several drinks
or by getting a taxi or lift which means
increased traffic outside
maybe even idling taxes
some of these people will be smokers
and as you cannot smoke inside they will
stand outside with their drinks or just
smoking
another increase of people wandering and
talking near me
not only that but there has to be noise
from the staff as they are going to be
working till an even later hour
the type of person who would be there
this late hour is january of the younger
element
i have been young myself i do remember
but i also see what comes out of the elk
bar
and also the people who are drinking
outside as they are open until two
and it is generally young
and should you be encouraging more late
night drinking because by definition
a pizza place is for young people
i'm not presuming that anybody has a
drink
sorry i am presuming that anybody that
has
has a drink has to have something to eat
which means it's going to be a kitchen
running late
or is it going to operate as a bar
and as a pizza place this is not what
should be happening
all this will considerably affect my
life my well-being and my health
as i will have no peace and quiet
whatsoever
as well as worrying for my safety
this weekend as i'm sure the licensing
committee will have been informed
there was an incident elk bar inside or
out which brought
four police cars
a police van
and an emergency ambulance
i believe if you increase the licensing
hours of vetoes
there is only going to be more of this
the shop below me had their plant
outside the shop
destructively broken on sunday evening
by a drunk
they have it on cctv
trying to headbutt it
and before that it was regularly being
used as a urinal
it is this kind of behavior you get with
alcohol and i don't want any more of it
living near me
i would also like to ask if this comes
at again
either this side or my other side
regarding the licensing hours
will i be contacted because i only found
out by accident
unless this directly affects me
i think i should have been notified so
that i would have chance to object
and i would like to have that in writing
because i would hate to think that you
would pass something through without
contacting me
and that is the end of my speech
thank you miss marshall um
i mean clearly some of those issues are
um issues which
aren't directly to do with
um with vetoes to do with other
establishments
and some come outside the licensing
regime i mean they can't serve
food hot food after 11 o'clock without a
an extension and they haven't they
haven't applied for one
um so
there's clearly
a few problems in the areas they're
probably using lots of areas but but you
can't
thin that down necessary to vetoes
although they've extended be applied to
extend the hours
you have actually offered to reduce that
slightly if there's any issues
specifically then we'd obviously have to
have to look at them um
you know but
problems arise unfortunately everywhere
at random you can't necessarily tie them
down to
to one particular
establishment
and
it's still in line or even
less than some of the other
establishments restaurants in the area
so their hours are less than
some of the other the other
establishments in the area but if
there's there's issues you know we can
we can certainly
look at them individually um but i'll
ask mr dunn if he wishes to comment on
any of the uh
the the the alleged issues that are
going along
you know around the restaurant
um yeah i could deal with them um
the incident alleged incident at elk on
saturday night was not actually elk it
was an incident outside the bowling
green where two of my members of staff
assisted
a member of the public who was being
assaulted
and
the assaulter was arrested by the police
until my members and staff gave
statements to the police to assist in
hopefully the conviction of the person
that carried out the assault so whilst
the police cars may have been parked
in or in and around the vicinity of the
elk bar there was not an incident in the
elk bar it was actually on out to the
bowling green
in the village so hopefully that
clarifies the position we're also elk
and i don't know why we're talking about
help because it is about vetoes
we don't have young people i'll give you
a prime example on saturday evening i
had
a group of people in trying to celebrate
a 50th birthday party
i can't serve them after 11 o'clock and
i've had to ask them to leave and go
across to well because they want to
continue to consume alcohol as part of
their celebratory meal and
that's the kind of customers that we
have this is not about
opening ourselves up to young people we
already have a bar across the road that
trades extremely well
i don't need another bar in the village
i've got a restaurant that i'm just
trying to make successful
and i don't need the off license i only
applied for it
because i thought i would i've already
got an off license out and we've already
offered to reduce the off-license hours
um
yeah i mean hopefully that assists you
okay thank you um
miss marshall is there anything else you
wish to
say
david where may i just um
um say something to miss marshall that's
all right
yes
um
is marshall i'm a counselor on the on
the committee um
i think you put a message up earlier
that you've not had the
um
the document pack
so
is that correct so you you are at a bit
of disadvantage in in not seeing
everything that's been
put forward um
i would also um make a
a comment which would prob
perhaps sound like a bit of hard word
but it's not intended to
i think you said that you'd lived
where you live now for 50 years
so
if that's the case then you've seen hale
village change substantially from
uh pretty much a village of of shops to
a village with a big nighttime economy
and
you you are now a neighbour of one of
those nighttime economy establishments
um
that change in that those particular
premises um
um
occupied
with the pizza restaurant um
that will have been a probably a
planning matter which you should have
been
notified about as
and would have had an opportunity to
make a representation on
um but that that ship has sailed
and
um
you are
now a close neighbor of um
a nighttime economy restaurant
and um
you are picking up some of the
inevitable
issues that arise um what i'm seeing
before us and what we've we've heard
from the solicitors and and from mr mr
dunn
um is that they've
uh reduced the request
for
the hours uh extension of the hours so
it is coming
it it's very much coming in line with
other establishments that are very close
to you
um not as close as the as as the um
the pizza premises vetoes but
um very much
the the sort of hours that hale village
is is operating on
and and i think
it's pretty much uh although it's no
consolation to you it's pretty much a
sign of the times of of what is
happening in
in hale village
so uh
whilst i accept you just a disadvantage
in not having all of the printed
information in front of you
i think it's fair to say
that
um
the management of vetoes
is making some moves towards you
um and
um
and in terms of their operation we'll be
you know looking at the issues of the
the use of the back door etc
um so
it's not particularly a question for you
but i just wanted to make um those
points to
to you because i think it just
perhaps you as i say you've been at a
disadvantage in not having all of the
documents that we've got at our disposal
so i'll
i'll stop there thank you
thank you mike that's that's beautiful
miss marshall is there anything you
wanted to to respond about
what you've heard
well only to say that i think midnight
is still too late i mean at the moment
what is quite interesting is that at the
moment
the pizza place is not opening to the
hours that it already has
it usually shuts at 9 30
they're not actually using until they're
11 o'clock
they may be occasionally on a saturday
if there's a party but generally
most of their
times or that it is shut at 9 30. so i
think
i accept that they have until 11 o'clock
existingly but i still
even though i haven't got the pack to me
midnight or midnight 30 is still too
late
it is very similar to pizza express it's
not a restaurant like the others it is a
small pizza
cafe
or restaurant whatever you want to call
it but pizza express is the most similar
establishment
to vetoes
okay thank you we don't usually get
complaints about establishments closing
too early but do understand where
you're coming from
um counselor young is there anything you
wish to say
well more or less everything i wanted to
say i think has been
virtually accomplished the point that
i'd just like to make
as a
hail central council though
is that
i want to support
the businesses that are open i want to
support places like
vetoes and make sure that they are
successful and that they do make a
profit because this is actually what we
need inhale but i also
want to do my level best to make quite
sure that all the people all the
residents inhale
manage to get quiet night sleep when
they want it
and there are quite a number of
residential areas
very very close
much closer actually to vetoes than they
are to
a number of the other restaurants that
you you're comparing them to
most of the areas on top of the shops
along that road actually have people
living in them
it's also very very close to the
residential houses at the bottom of
westgate
so this keeping all this in the back of
my mind i really do feel that the hours
they have got allowed to them now which
is open till around 11 p.m at night it's
actually more than adequate i do think
that going on till midnight is actually
that hour too long
so i really would ask that the hours are
left until
it is 2 300 hours
when really they close
now so if you could just bear that in
mind when thinking about things
thank you councillor young does anybody
have any questions of the representative
no thank you dave
no
okay um
okay well now now we come to the to the
summaries which is
probably a case of for repeating
ourselves really but um if i can start
with uh you miss marshall if you'd just
like to summarize uh your case for
representation against
the application
well just summarize i would just say
that i
like counselor
um patricia said i think the hours
should stay as they are
i don't see any justification for them
to go
any higher
i think there are adequate amounts of
restaurants in hale village
and that
the only reason they want it is to sell
more alcohol
it is alcohol that makes profit not
pizzas
okay thank you
um counselor young do you do you want to
say anything in some summary
not sure i think i've said everything
but i've had to say i do appreciate the
fact that eamonn is trying to
to um get on with his neighbors and
i just urge him to sort of keep a
personal eye on the way it's being run
maybe a bit more closely
in the future just to make sure that the
conditions that should be happening if
they operate to the conditions given
there shouldn't be any problems
so
you know this is just what i'd like to
ask
okay thank you for that councillor young
um
okay in in that case mr do you want to
respond on behalf of
vito's restaurant and mr dunn please
thank you chair only very briefly
because everything will obviously be
fresh in your mind
um we would ask you to grant the
application in its amended form um
i set out at the outset uh four or five
changes so a reduction in the hours and
the addition of several conditions
um there has been further discussion
around the emptying of bottle bins
um
into an external bin and then preventing
that from happening in the evenings
obviously that's a matter for you but
eamonn would have no issue with the
conditions such as that being posed on
the license uh councillor young's
absolutely right when she says that it's
it's about balance um she wants to
support local businesses but also
weigh that up and balance that up with
the um the needs of local residents um
and eamonn is exactly of the same view
um he believes that the amendments that
have been made strike that balance and
with the conditions that
um already on the license or been agreed
subsequently with the environmental
health officer and the further ones i've
gone through this evening um will ensure
the promotion of the licensing
objectives are upheld because ultimately
that's what underpins the licensing act
and that's what needs to govern your
decision um when when coming to it this
evening so
yeah that's all i'd like to say thank
you chair
thank you mr
okay that so that concludes the
submissions what we're going to do now
is we'll retire
um to deliberate on the application and
and we'll come back with the decision uh
and reasons for the decision
so we could ask natalie to to put us
into the breakout room please